let's talk about stress unfortunately
we are all being bathed in chronic
stress literally 24 7. and this is just
not healthy there are certain
individuals and groups that are
constantly putting out
your environment is very dangerous okay
danger danger danger and as we are more
exposed to this uh threat of danger it
can really affect every single system in
our body but there's one thing that's
very very important and I want to just
talk about it and that really is
changing your Viewpoint about the
environment I know this might be hard to
believe but your environment is not
quite as dangerous as they want you to
believe now it is dangerous don't get me
wrong and there's certain individuals
that profit from keeping the public in a
fierce State and many times they
exaggerate this and it's just not a
healthy thing to keep our attention on
this negativity 24 7. so I want you to
do something right now I want you just
to look outside right now okay what do
you see
you see any
dangerous things I see a tree out there
I don't see any hurricanes no tsunamis
looks pretty safe out there
now look at the ground look at the floor
right now
are you sitting on a potential sinkhole
do you feel that there's any termites
that have destroyed your foundation that
you're gonna just cave right in
the answer is no
all right so go ahead and put your hand
on the wall next to you right
do you feel it hot like there's Flames
like your house is on fire
no but if you think about it if the
average person were to just to absorb
all this threat of danger 24 7. I don't
even know how they can survive so the
most important thing to do is to really
change your Viewpoint and start to
filter out some of the things that
you're exposed to recently I started to
really look at videos I was watching and
different TV programs I was watching and
it just hit me how many messages of fear
I was exposed to and without any
solutions so anytime someone gives you
some Doom and Gloom message without a
solution don't watch it why because now
you're going to start solving these
problems when you should be sleeping now
I'm definitely not saying to ignore some
of these dangers but when you are
exposed to these dangers try like heck
to have a relaxed Viewpoint staying in
action to help solve the problem improve
things but at some point we need to
start filtering out this threat of
danger because it's just not not healthy
for our bodies that also includes the
people that you hang out with I mean
there are so many people out there I've
had people around me that would only
give me bad news okay never any good
news you should start watching TV
programs and hang out with people that
give you solutions that emphasize the
good news talk about the good things to
offset the massive danger signals that
our body is constantly being
fed now let me just go through a couple
things because this is actually a very
important topic
you have the sympathetic nervous system
okay that's the flutter fight the
protective mode that we go into for this
threat of stress and every single cell
in our body changes to a whole different
program whereas the other system called
the parasympathetic is all about growth
sleep digestion repair
healing okay that's a completely
different program in practice I used to
have a test it was called that heart
rate durability test that would measure
how much sympathetic nervous system that
was being activated versus how much
parasympathetic and boy nearly everyone
that came in were just so jacked up to
the right which is sympathetic dominance
simply because the environment that
we're in was considered extremely
dangerous and I will say a certain
amount of that has been manufactured I
mean if there's not enough things going
wrong to have other people manufacturing
more of that is complete Insanity so I
think it's important for you to
understand
what happens to your biology when you
are under sustained chronic stress first
of all you're going to have less
Diversified
microbiome and you're going to have more
pathogenic bacteria so your entire gut
microbiome changes and all the points
I'm going to mention today are based on
some research on relating chronic
sympathetic High cortisol stress to the
various systems of your body let's go on
to the immune system what happens to
your immune system when you have this
sustained stress it shuts down the T
cells that are normally there to protect
you and kill cancer cells and kill
viruses
are basically put to sleep the duration
of infections take way longer you have
what's called immunosuppression stress
suppresses the immune system
and this is why when you go to the
doctor and you have inflammation or some
type of autoimmune they inject you with
prednisone which takes that away
temporarily because prednisone is a type
of cortisol which is produced by the
adrenal glands which is activated by
stress and that is suppressing all the
immune reactions and as soon as it wears
off you start getting a lot more
inflammation so stress will increase
inflammation all right what about
fertility do you become more fertile no
you become less fertile you have
decreased sperm production you have less
implanting of the egg in the uterus so
you become less fertile you usually lose
your menstrual cycle and on top of that
you lose your libido usually when people
are stressed out they don't have any sex
drive all right now what happens to the
fuel system in your body well if you're
trying to be on the ketogenic diet your
whole metabolism shifts back to glucose
production that's right because cortisol
is a glucocorticoid so it starts to
increase gluco neogenesis the production
of new sugar in your liver
so when you go through stress okay
chronically what's happening is you're
just pumping out all this sugar that's
not coming from your diet it's coming
from your proteins the muscle proteins
in your butt the the muscle proteins in
your legs and even fat and ketones are
turned into glucose and that glucose can
then increase insulin and you increase
your risk of getting a diabetes Now why
is this because when you're in stress
mode your body needs this quick energy
what about lipids like cholesterol and
things like that this is interesting
when you go through chronic stress your
triglycerides go up your HDL goes down
your LDL goes up and if you had these
large buoyant particle size type LDL
that's going to switch to the small
dense particle size which are the more
pathogenic ones that actually can invade
the arteries
so your profile for cholesterol gets
much worse when you go through stress
like I said before having a non-serious
relaxed State of Mind is so important
now this next one is really interesting
too your ability to detoxify I'm talking
about these certain enzymes in your
liver they're called cytochrome p450
phase one phase two enzymes okay these
are the enzymes that convert poisons
into harmless water-soluble things that
can be released from the body so we're
going from fat soluble poisons
the harmless particles right
well guess what those are inhibited when
you go through chronic stress wild so
you can't detoxify that well so you're
going to hold toxins right what about
digestion as a whole well you're going
to have much slower digestion you're not
going to be able to release the bile
salts from your liver which is
interesting so there goes the fat
digestion even your pancreatic enzymes
in your enzymes from your small
intestine will be inhibited thereby
cutting down your ability to digest your
production of hydrochloric acid is going
to go down too so there goes your
complete digestion of proteins your
absorption of minerals and the killing
of pathogens your mucous lining in the
stomach in the small intestine and the
large bowel is inhibited by this stress
State as well and that's kind of like
the immune barrier and then your overall
absorption of vitamins and minerals are
going to be lessened now this next one
is also interesting
vitamin D absorption there's a receptor
for vitamin D called the vitamin D
receptor okay and the reception or the
absorption of vitamin D through that
receptor is diminished with stress on
top of all the other barriers with
vitamin D
stress will actually slow down the
absorption of vitamin D wild even the
fascia kind of like the the stuff that
surrounds the muscles that's highly
innovated by your nerves and your brain
has a lot of information coming down to
the fascia around the ligaments around
your muscles becomes tighter becomes
more restricted you lose your range of
motion you lose your blood flow to your
fascia when you're under chronic stress
you maintain this posture right here
right which is kind of like in protect
mode this is your flight or fight you
know your posture starts going down and
it all has to do with that fascia now
what happens to the brain when you're
under chronic sustained sympathetic
nervous system overdrive well the
hippocampus the structure that's
involved with the relay of memories and
learning and cognition is all inhibited
because that part of the brain starts to
shrink also it starts lowering the
function of your cerebral cortex you
kind of need that part of the brain now
another structure is activated in your
brain and I don't know if you ever heard
about the structure but it's called the
amygdala
the amygdala has everything to do with
fear
and anxiety okay it's kind of like your
adrenal glands but in the brain so it's
going to react to stress States now as
far as thinking in a chronic state of
stress you're not going to be really
analytically thinking about things
solving problems coming up with good
Solutions being creative having
imagination instead it's going to be
more like
reaction mode because you need a relaxed
State of Mind to come up with Solutions
you need your creativity to come up with
really good strategies and solutions
last point I want to bring up is your
genes what happens to your genes when
you're under stress well all the bad
genes get activated okay and all the
good genes get suppressed like I'm
talking about activation of cancer genes
I'm talking about activation of
inflammatory genes things like that but
one thing I want to bring up your genes
really don't cause anything okay they
don't cause the problems for you it's
the epigenetics which means above
genetics it's your lifestyle that's
really Behind These genetics and all you
need to understand is how to turn on and
turn off certain genes and those
switches are activated by certain
lifestyle changes and I cover these
Lifestyle Changes in a lot of my videos
the genes are associated with a lot of
bad things but if you know how to
control your genes you're totally going
to be in the driver's seat number one we
must change our attitude our Viewpoint
of our environment we must also start
filtering out how much threat of danger
we're exposed to if you start watching
certain videos that don't give you a
solution that at the end of the video
you feel worse than before you watch the
video then you might need to filter
those things out a therapy for me is
getting out in nature getting a lot of
space as much as possible
and really kind of getting connected to
my environment now the other thing to do
is to physically
flesh out a lot of this extra adrenaline
and this extra cortisol that has been
accumulated through the day of exposure
to all these things so this means uh
routine consistent exercise okay
physical work outside so you can start
flushing out these neurotransmitters and
hormones that are creating a lot of this
damage because the last thing you want
to do is go through a lot of mental
stress and then just go to bed at night
you're not going to sleep that well so
exercise is a necessity I mean I have to
physically work out every single day
just to kind of flush out things and
help me sleep because the other point
about the adrenaline and cortisol it's
shifting a lot of energy okay that
should be in your immune system should
be in repair should be in your digestion
and it's ending up in the muscles so you
have enough energy to run away from the
tiger right but because there's no more
tiger around we have more mental energy
and that whole mechanism is still there
so you're gonna have to exercise to get
those hormones out of your system now
that being said there's a lot of
additional things you can do to help
with stress not as important as changing
your viewpoint but they're still
important and I put that video up right
here check it out